The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
IAIN STEWART: So
last time we were
talking about the subleading
one of our MQ Lagrangian HQET.
Hopefully more people
remember that we
have a makeup lecture
today, or will not
be stopped by the snow.
So today we're going to continue
this discussion of power
suppressed Lagrangians.
And I'll explain
to you why we think
of these as giving power
corrections to observables.
And we'll talk about a
couple different observables
where these specific operators
are playing an important role.
And then we're going to turn
to the topic of renormalons,
which is fun stuff.
How many people here know
what a renormalon is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
By the end of the lecture, you
all know what a renormalon is.
OK, so this is
where we left off.
We were talking about this
symmetry reparameterization
invariance.
And what we showed last time
is that the Wilson coefficient
of this operator is 1 to all
orders in perturbation theory
because of that symmetry.
The Wilson coefficient
of this operator is not.
And I told you that
at leading log order,
it would be given by some
expression like this.
But in general, this is just
the lowest order expression.
And it gets
perturbatively corrected.
It's actually known
at three loops.
So let's continue.
We've talked about
reparameterization invariance
for the Lagrangian.
Reparameterization
invariance also
has important consequences
for operators.
So just like we wrote down
sub-leading Lagrangians,
we should also write
sub-leading currents.
So there's 1 over mq
supressed currents.
And if you look
at those currents
and you construct them,
then you find, again,
that reparameterization
invariance
plays an important role.
And again, there's relations
between Wilson coefficients.
And what happens in
this case is actually
that the leading order operator
had a Wilson coefficient,
the lowest order operator.
So the Wilson coefficients
of the subleading operators
get related to that of
the leading operator.
And I may give you a problem on
that on your next problem set.
But I haven't quite
made up my mind yet.
So rather than go
through that, I
want to talk about
some observables where
these operators played a role.
So we've seen one example of
reparameterization invariance.
And I think from
that one example,
you would be able to
do other examples.
Let's talk about masses.
These operators here
actually have an impact
on the masses of hadrons.
If we think about the
mass of a heavy meson, h,
there's a heavy quark
in that heavy meson.
So we can pull out
that heavy quark.
And then there's some remainder.
And we can characterize higher
order terms in this formula.
So let me first explain
what this lambda bar is.
Our Lagrangian here, if
we're working at lowest order
in the theory, our Lagrangian
would be L0 of HQET plus,
for the light quarks,
they're basically
just a QCD Lagrangian,
so for the light quarks
and the gluons.
So for the heavy
quark, we have HQET,
and then there would
be higher order
terms that are 1
over m suppressed,
which are the ones up there.
So the question is, if
we have this Lagrangian,
what is the mass of a heavy
state like the b meson
or the d meson or the d star?
And we can characterize that
by knowing the structure
of the Lagrangian.
So first of all, what about
this term, this lambda bar?
That term actually comes from
these parts of the Lagrangian.
So if we take these
parts of the Lagrangian,
we can calculate
the Hamiltonian.
Let me call that H0.
And the definition
of this lambda bar
is the thing that you get
by taking that Hamiltonian
and letting it act on the state.
So you can think that this is--
if you like, you can think
that this state is just
an eigenstate of
the Hamiltonian.
You get the energy.
But since the Hamiltonian has
no heavy quark mass in it,
what you're getting
is some parameter,
which is traditionally called
lambda bar, that doesn't
have a heavy quark mass in it.
And so there's no heavy
quark mass in here.
So it's independent of mq.
It's also independent of spin.
So B versus B star and
flavor B versus D. So
whether it's a B
meson, D meson, as long
as we're in this limit
where both the bottom mass
and the char mass
are heavy, if we're
thinking of this
expansion, then this
is a universal thing
just determined
by these Lagrangians.
It's traditionally
called lambda bar.
And it's telling you that if
you think about this thing
as having an order
mq piece, this
is the order mq to the 0 piece.
The symmetry of the
theory is telling us
that this is a
universal constant.
It does depend on
the state here,
although that state could
be connected to other states
by spin symmetry
and flavor symmetry.
There was this quantum number
we talked about last time, which
we called SL for the spin of
the light degrees of freedom,
and then pi for the parity of
the light degrees of freedom.
So it's the same
within every multiplet
that we get from a fixed SL pi.
But there's a different
value for each multiplet.
So you'd have a
different value of lambda
bar for the B, D, B star B than
for the lambda B and the lambda
C, for example.
So that's this term.
We can also characterize
what's going on with this term
by using this
Lagrangian here, the L1.
So at order 1 over
MQ, we can figure out
what kind of contributions
to the mass we're getting.
h1 is just minus L1.
You can think of it
now perturbatively.
So that just flips the
sign of what we had before.
And we get two parameters from
taking matrix elements here.
They get the following names.
And let me just do
everything here in terms of--
it's not totally
crucial, but it's
a little easier to
interpret certain things
if we work in the rest frame.
So I'll just work
in the rest frame.
So if you work in
the rest frame,
you should just think
of this as like giving
some kind of measure
of the kinetic energy
that the heavy quark
gets wiggled by.
And that's called lambda 1.
This, again, is a matrix
element that doesn't know
about the heavy quark mass.
And the heavy quark
mass in an explicit MQ.
So this guy has dimension 2 if
you work out the dimensions.
And then you can do the
same for the other operator.
And here you have to
think a little bit harder.
And if you think a
little bit harder,
you can characterize
what the coefficients
are for different spins.
So there's some
Wilson coefficient.
And then we have this operator.
And this here is like sigma
dot B. I told you that before.
And so you should
think of what's
going on here as you have
sigma, which is giving the SQ,
and then you have a B field.
And then it's a
question of what vector
could be left over that the
B field could know about.
And it's basically SL.
So this guy here is
leading to the SQ.
And this guy here is
leading to the SL.
And so that's where
this SQ.SL comes from.
So you can think about
other possibilities,
but you have to have
the right symmetry
structure under time
reversal and parity
and things like that.
And that forces you
to use a spin here
for the B and not
something like the V.
So this SQ.SL is something
that you can write out
as, remembering the definition
of it and its relation to J
squared.
You can write out
that factor like that.
And then we can derive here
how this lambda 2 contributes
to the differing
states, because we
have a different
contribution for the B
and the B star from
the lambda 2 guy,
because it was violating
the spin symmetry.
So the lambda 1 guy is going
to violate the flavor symmetry.
That's this 1 over MQ.
And so charm quarks--
charm mesons and
bottom mesons will
get different
contributions from that.
They have the same
lambda 1, but they
have a different connection
because it gets suppressed
by a different factor.
And then again for
the lamba 2, Lambda 2
is a little bit different
because it actually
has mu dependents.
That's not quite right.
So it actually has MQ dependents
because the coefficient here
has mu dependents.
So this operator doesn't
have any MQ dependence,
but the coefficient
does, remember.
The mu dependence cancels
and there's a left over MQ
dependence to the lambda 2, but
it's logarithmic MQ dependence.
If I define it this way--
so that's why I wrote MQ there.
So you could, as we
talked about last time,
you could sum up the logs of
large logs and have this guy--
you could re-sum
logs, if you want.
So you could think of
these as you can re-sum
logs inside this lambda 2.
So if we ignore those logs or
we imagine that we re-sum them
and we just look
at the remainder,
then we have the expectations
based on power counting
for how big these things are.
And we just [? expect ?]
that they're
both given by the dimension.
And the only
[? dimensionful ?] parameter
around is lambda QCD
because the MQs can only
occur in logarithms, and the
Wilson coefficient in nowhere
else.
And these are
non-perturbative parameters.
Lambda bar is also a
non-perturbative parameter.
These ones have a little
more dynamics in them.
So then we could go out
and write for our states
the results by putting
these things together.
So we'd have M capital
B plub M little B
plus lambda bar lambda
1 over 2 and little B.
And if we go through the
spin structure there,
we get a 3/2 and then
lamba 2 logarithmic MB
dependence over MB.
So when we start
with the B star,
the first three
terms are the same.
And then this guy
comes in with a plus.
And it's lambda 2
over MB over 2MB.
And then the D states
are similar in turn.
Lambda bar lambda 1 over 2M
term, and then these two terms
again.
Same spins, so it's lambda 2.
And the only difference
is, now we're
evaluating the lambda 2 as
logarithm and charm dependence,
OK.
So there's some formulas
that are correct, actually--
including all the way up
to 1 over M corrections.
And you can see that
there's still sort
of a structure to these things.
This is a universal
correction for all of them.
These corrections are
universal between B and B star.
And so the splitting
between B and B star
is just given by this lambda 2.
That's what causes
the states to split.
So up to that level,
they're the same.
And that's why the B and
B star are very degenerate
and the masses are very close.
So you can form combinations
to cancel things out.
So you can take a kind of
spin average mass where
you take 3 times the vector
plus the scalar divided by 4.
And if you do that, then you're
canceling out the lambda 2.
And then you can also
form differences.
So if you looked at MV star
squared minus MB squared,
then the only thing that's
causing a difference
is lambda 2.
Numerically, this
is 0.49 GV squared.
And from our formula up
there, it's 4 lambda 2 of MB,
so something like four
times 0.12 GV squared.
So that's the value
of this lambda
2 is 0.12 GV squared, which
is about lambda QCD squared.
So our dimensional
analysis is working.
And then you can do the
same thing for the D meson.
Everything here works
beautifully, actually.
Extract the value
of lambda 2 and you
see there's a slight difference
because that difference can be
attributed to the logarithms.
So if you take lambda
2 MB over lambda 2 MC,
then the only thing that differs
is the Wilson coefficient.
So that's something
you can predict.
So experimentally, if you take
the ratio of those two things
there, you get a
prediction like this one.
And if you plug in theory
like leading log RGE,
then you're getting
alpha S of MB.
Oh, sorry.
[INAUDIBLE]
And this is 1.17.
So that's for three
light flavors,
which is the right thing to
do for the beta function.
So it's not so bad for a
leading log prediction.
That's kind of the
accuracy you would expect.
All right.
So we're really
understanding quite a bit
from our [INAUDIBLE]
[? instruction ?]
of this effective
theory about the states,
and even make predictions for
the ratios of the mass divided
by that as something
preservative, which
is kind of non-trivial.
Perturbative up to the
order we were working.
There would be corrections if
we continued in our series here.
There could be some
non-perturbative corrections.
But up to 1 over M,
the ratio of this
to that, which is what I'd wrote
over there, is perturbative.
All right.
So that's some phenomenology.
It's kind of baseline
phenomenology
that we can do with
the Hamiltonian
or with Hamiltonian derived
from our subleading Lagrangian.
There's other phenomenology
that we can do.
And I'll mention some of the
most important phenomenology.
There's another
class of predictions
that we can make where we
have a lot of predictive power
by using the effective theory.
And I want to talk a
little bit about that.
So you can look at
semi-leptonic decays.
And there's two different types
of semi-leptonic decays that
you can look at--
so-called exclusive decays
and inclusive decays.
So exclusive is
making transitions
between the meson
states and inclusive
is making a transition where you
allow any charm state, not just
the lowest order
ground state charm,
but you could have in
this state here, XE, you
could have a D pi or a D star
pi pi or other things like that.
So it doesn't even have to
be a single hadron state.
So exclusive refers to
a particular channel.
Inclusive refers to
some overall channels.
So the theory in these
two is quite different.
In this one, you would have
form factors for the current
between the states.
And I already mentioned to
you that heavy quark symmetry
reduces the number
of form factors.
You get this single
Isgur-Wise function.
And so heavy quark symmetry
is very powerful here.
And you can actually also work
out 1 over MQ corrections.
And people have done that.
And it turns out
there aren't any.
So there's something called
Luke's theorem, which actually
was a result derived,
I think, when
Luke was a graduate student that
proved there was no 1 over m Q
corrections here.
And then you can work
out alpha s corrections.
And so this kind of--
you can just keep going.
People have worked out 1
over m Q squared corrections.
And this kind of
formalism is used
to measure V c b because
these decay rates would depend
on V c b, and that's
kind of what you're
after if you're doing this.
So you'd like to
parameterize and figure out
the hadronic physics
as much as possible,
and aid the experiments
in getting V c b,
and exactly this
framework is used.
People nowadays-- what
they do is, the 1 over m Q
squared corrections need to
be computed on the lattice.
So lattice QCD computes
those corrections.
The perturbative
corrections need
to be computed by
continuum people like me,
so those are computed.
And they put these
things together
to get V c b from these decays.
You could also do it
with this inclusive guy.
And here it's more interesting
because you can basically do
everything with pen and paper.
So here, you can use an
Operator Product Expansion, OPE.
And actually, HQET constrains
the form of the operator
product expansion, as well.
And indeed, when you work out
the leading power corrections,
they turn out to not enter
until two orders down.
So again, you're protected
from first-order corrections,
so you just get corrections that
occur at 1 over m Q squared.
And furthermore, they depend
only on the two parameters
we already defined.
So it's not like you even get
any new nonperturbative matrix
comments.
You just get the two we
were talking over here,
were the masses.
OK?
So there's perturbation
corrections,
and there's power corrections,
but you're actually
not even getting
any new information
relative to the masses,
any new matrix elements.
OK?
So we'll talk a little bit
more about this second one
with the OPE.
There's a lot of
work that's gone
into this one, both
from the theory side,
as well as from experiment.
So when you think about
the decay rate for this B
to X sub c l nu bar, it's a
doubly differential decay rate
in Q squared over the lepton
pair, so that's Q mu, E l--
because you can pick it
as a second variable--
and then you don't know
the mass of the state
X sub c because it could
be different things.
It could be a D. It
could be a D star.
It could be a D pi.
So that's another variable.
So you have a triply
differential spectrum,
and you can compute it with
an operator product expansion.
I'm not going to go through
the details of carrying out
the operator product expansion.
If you want to do
reading about that,
there's some
supplemental reading
that I haven't
assigned to you where
you can read about
that in the book
Heavy Quark Physics
by Manohar and Wise.
So for our purposes here, let's
think of what operator product
expansion means.
It is simply that
we want to carry out
an expansion in
lambda QCD over m Q.
And if you go into
the details, there's
an important role
played by the fact
that you're summing
over all states,
and that's allowing
you to connect
the partonic calculations to
the hadronic calculations,
basically by probability
conservation,
but I'm not going to
go so much into that.
So when you do this
operator product expansion,
you can think of it
in terms of diagrams.
And usually, you draw these
diagrams as forward diagrams.
So here's kind of the
matrix elements squared.
Here is the final state.
There's the b quark going in
and another b quark going out,
so that's like a
matrix element squared.
The amplitude squared.
And you think about doing an
operator product expansion
for that.
And you match onto operators
in the effective theory.
Just to give you a schematic
structure for those operators.
So there's a
leading-order operator.
There's a
subleading-order operator
that has an extra
covariant derivative in it.
That's kind of
what you would do.
And then you have
Wilson coefficients.
The leading-order operator
here is just b bar b.
That's what it turns out to be.
This operator here
would look familiar
because it's D
transverse squared,
so that's like our
lambda 1 operator,
and that's where the lambda
1's are going to come from.
And then there would
be a lambda 2 term,
and I just didn't write it.
So there's a magnetic
guy here, too.
So when you look at the
leading-order operator,
b bar b, that counts the
number of b quarks, OK?
That's just a number operator.
So to all orders in perturbation
theory, b bar b is 1.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How do you cut these--
like, you're
actually calculating
[? B to A, right? ?] [INAUDIBLE]
IAIN STEWART: Right.
So you should think
of actually looking--
so this is a charm quark.
And so you would write
down that propagator,
and then you have a large
injection of momentum
from the b quark, right?
Use momentum conservation
and expand the propagator.
Thinking about the
propagator, if you like,
thinking about this
guy here having--
so you could write this guy's
momentum as m b v plus k,
all right?
And you would expand in k.
So at first order, you just
drop all the k's, and that's
basically giving you this term.
At second order,
you'd keep the k's,
so the k squared
would be identified
with this D t squared.
AUDIENCE: Right, but how do you
cut the effective [INAUDIBLE]??
IAIN STEWART: The effective
theory diagram, it's
already been cut, if you like.
So this is just a real
thing, and I've already
taken the imaginary part.
So this is all real.
There's no cut to make
in the effective theory.
The thing I'm
integrating out here--
so this is a good comment.
The thing I'm integrating out
here is hard and off-shell.
So when I go over to
the effective theory
and I get rid of the off-shell
stuff, I have a real part here.
There's nothing to cut
in the effective theory.
Sometimes, as you
know, there are
things to cut in the
effective theory,
but here there's nothing
to cut on this side.
OK, so this is one tall order.
So that actually means
that we don't even
have a nontrivial
matrix element here.
We just have a
Wilson coefficient.
So everything in the first-order
term is completely calculable.
No nonperturbative parameter
because of symmetry.
And this guy here is
the power correction.
And if you look at what
the Wilson coefficient is--
so it's a function of alpha s.
You could think of it
like this, if you want.
And all the kinematic variables,
like kinematic variables
like these guys--
and it is equal to the free b
quark decay, including the loop
corrections, of course.
So not only the
tree-level result,
but adding loop corrections
to the right-hand side here.
If you add the loop
corrections and you
drop all the k squared's, then
you get just the free b quark
decay, no nonperturbative
matrix elements,
so you can just calculate that
first term, order by order.
Just doing a
[? partonic ?] calculation
gives you the right thing
to describe this decay.
And the OPE is telling
you that that formally
is exactly the right thing.
Even if you just
started to do it,
it's actually technically
the right thing to do here.
It wouldn't be the right thing
to do for the exclusive decays,
but it is the right thing to
do here for the inclusive.
So what is the range of
validity of this sort of--
is there any restrictions on
these kinematic variables?
And there is.
We're treating the kinematic
variables as if they're hard.
And that means
basically that we're
thinking that they scale like
powers of the heavy quark mass.
So there can be
regions of phase space
where that wouldn't
be true, but as long
as we stay away from
those corners, edges, then
what I said is right.
And it's a little more
powerful than that.
So stay away from edges.
Or there's another way
of thinking about it,
and that is that you
can integrate over
regions of the Dalitz plane
for the phase-space variables.
That includes all the
way up to the edges.
And as long as the size
of your integration region
is order m Q, then
you're also fine.
So think of, like,
something with,
like, m B squared up here,
d m x squared, for example.
And you can-- it doesn't have
to be exactly m B squared.
It could be m B squared over 2,
m B squared over 4, something
that you're counting
as order m B squared.
And again, you would be
fine with doing this type
of operator product expansion.
So what happens is, if
you restrict yourself
to be close to the
edges, then restricting
yourself to be close
to the edges introduces
new scales in the problem.
And if there's new
scales in the problem,
just having a power counting
that separates out lambda, QCD,
and m B would not be enough.
You would have to
do more detail.
And there is actually
some interesting things
that happen there,
and we probably
will talk about at least
one example later on when
we talk about [? SCT. ?]
OK, so I already said it,
that there's a nontrivial fact
happening at NLO.
Well, I already
implied that there's
no 1 over m b
corrections, and so that's
an important outcome
from this result.
If you want to derive this,
you need the effective theory.
You basically use the
equation of motion
to get that to be true.
So this is NLO in the
power corrections,
and then NNLO as I said, is
just lambda 1 and lambda 2
at order lambda QCD
squared over m b squared.
So phenomenologically, this
is actually wildly successful.
This is-- as far as I
know, this is the case
in QCD or in any theory
where people have actually
carried out the operator product
expansion in the most detail.
So people have gone up
to 1 over m Q to the 4th.
So they calculated
at least two loops
for everything and maybe even
three loops for the [? NF ?]
pieces.
And experimentally it's
been explored to death.
You have these three
variables, and they've
constructed of order 80
moments from these three
different kinematic
variables, sliced
and diced the decay
rate in all sorts
of imaginative and crazy ways.
And they've really tested
that this OPE [? always ?]
works beautifully, OK?
So you can think of that you're
getting a consistent picture,
80 different observables, just
from a few simple predictions
and your perturbative results.
You also get v c b.
So everything fits together
with the framework agreement
I've discussed with you, and
you get a result for v c b,
which I'm not going
to write on the board.
OK?
So that gives you--
I didn't go through the details.
I will give you some reading
to learn more about this OPE
if you're interested, and
sort of [? seize ?] how
some of the things I
mentioned, like using
the equation of motion, how
that actually works out.
It's all done very nicely in
this book, Heavy Quark Physics.
But I just wanted
to give you a flavor
with this effective
theory that there's
something very useful you can
do with it once you have it.
And in this case, kind of the
main phenomenological thing
that you're after is v c b and
what I've described to you,
but you could also
think about b decays,
where you're looking
for new physics.
And again, if you can construct
how the decay rate is looking,
then you can have
a hope of finding
new physics in the coefficient
of those decay rates,
effectively in the Wilson
coefficients of decay rates.
OK?
So we're going to turn
to something else,
but let me pause and see
if there's any questions.
AUDIENCE: Is this the best
way to [? get ?] [? v c b? ?]
IAIN STEWART: The two are
actually pretty competitive,
the exclusive and inclusive.
Basically because
the lattice is doing
a good job of the
matrix elements
that you need in the exclusive.
And again, you have a lot
of kinematic information
you can use from the
experiment on the shape.
So they're pretty
competitive, actually.
AUDIENCE: Do they agree?
IAIN STEWART: They agree--
I think the disagreement is
at, like, kind of the 1.8 sigma
level, so they agree.
There's an interesting
story in v u b.
So you could do the same kind
of thing, not for a charm quark,
as we did here, but
for a light quark.
And then actually, if
you do b to pi l nu
and you look at the
inclusive version of that,
and you can do the
same type of OPE--
a little bit
different, actually,
but you can do it in
OPE there, as well.
Then you go through
and you get a v u
b in the two different
ways, and the disagreement's
at the 2 and 1/2 sigma
level, maybe even-- yeah.
It fluctuates with time, but on
average it's 2 and 1/2 sigma.
[CHUCKLES]
So that's interesting.
There's not an understanding
of what's going on there.
That's more interesting than--
this one basically agrees.
OK, so rather than
go further into this,
I want to turn now to my
promised topic to you,
to tell you about renormalons.
Actually, renormalons
have something
to do with power
correction, so it's not
disconnected from what
we've been talking about.
So what are the ideas here?
So we've already seen in our
discussion of renormalization
that there is a
freedom in defining
the perturbative series.
And we kind of focused
on the m s bar scheme
as being the simplest thing.
But I told you about some
subtleties with m s bar,
and now we're going
to address one
of them that's related to
this thing called renormalons.
So we have some freedom, if you
like, in adjusting the cutoffs.
And we had this
cutoff, mu, and it
was dividing up what
was perturbative and
nonperturbative in m s bar.
But we could have
done something else.
We could have used a
different type of cutoff.
We could have used
a Wilsonian cutoff,
and that would have divided
up things a little bit
differently.
And you should ask the
question, are any possible way
of dividing things
up equivalent?
We've already saw when we
were doing calculations
that, for the logarithms,
they were equivalent.
But it turns out
that, if you don't--
that the powers, sort
of the power separation
of power divergences can
actually have an impact.
And that's related to
what renormalons are.
And m s bar and
dim reg basically
avoids thinking about
power corrections.
You just set them to zero.
And so what can
happen is, in m s bar,
your matrix elements are
having a little bit too much UV
physics, and your Wilson
coefficients are actually
sensitive to the IR.
They're not sensitive--
you don't really
see it when you look
at the coefficient.
You just see a number,
and it looks pretty good,
but there's actually
an asymptotic structure
to those Wilson
coefficients that
comes from higher orders
of perturbation theory.
There's things hiding there.
That's what this discussion
is going to be about.
So if you do actually
not make a good choice,
then it can be
the case that when
you go to higher orders in
the perturbative expansion,
you get lousy convergence.
And that goes
hand-in-hand, actually,
with kind of another thing,
which is harder to visualize,
but I'll explain it.
And that is that you
have trouble extracting
the nonperturbative parameters.
And the reason that
you're having trouble--
so you could think about
doing some calculation
like that OPE over there.
And you extract a value for
lambda 1 from all your fits
to all these moments I
was describing to you.
And then you go to one
higher order in alpha s,
and you extract another
value, and all of a sudden,
this guy changes
by a factor of 2
and you wonder what's going on.
And you wonder, well,
what's nature telling you
about the kinetic
energy if I change
the order of my perturbation
theory and all of a sudden I'm
extracting a factor of 2
different value for that matrix
element.
And that's related actually
to this poor convergence.
These things go hand in hand.
If there's pure
convergence in the series,
then when you extract
matrix elements
you can get different values.
Phenomenologically,
you can imagine
how that would be related, but
it's physically related, too.
It has to do with the fact that
there's a poor convergence here
because you haven't
divided up the IR physics
and the UV physics
fully correctly,
and that's reflected
in this inability
to extract these guys
in a convergent fashion.
And we can actually quantify
that using something
called renormalon techniques.
So one way of saying it is
that, if you make a poor choice,
you're plagued by something
called renormalons,
so they're actually something
bad and you don't want them.
So what goes wrong is that the
short distance of coefficients
have hidden power law
sensitivity to the IR.
You wanted these
to be UV things,
but they are
sensitive to the IR.
And it comes in dimensional
regularization in the powers.
We've been very careful about
separating out logarithms,
but we weren't as
careful about powers,
and it comes back to haunt
us if we look carefully
at the theory.
And there's a
corresponding sensitivity
to the UV in the
matrix elements.
So let me give you
an example that's
not working through
formalism, but just numerics.
So let's look at b to u
e bar nu at lowest order.
The up quark is massless.
And we'll think
about this-- like we
were talking about
for the OPE for charm,
we'll think about it inclusively
so that we can actually just
look at this and it
makes physical sense.
The same thing that I told
you about the charm case
applies for the up quark case.
The lowest-order prediction
is just calculate this guy
and include loop corrections.
The leading power
prediction is the same story
as for the charm.
So that means that
physically it's
relevant to think
about this decay rate.
So what does it look like?
There's some G Fermi.
Integrating out the W boson.
There's some factors of pi.
The mass dimensions
of this guy are 1.
G Fermi squared is minus
4, so you need 5 powers,
and the thing that's the
setting the mass dimensions
is m b, so you get
5 powers of m b.
And if you look at the
perturbative series
and you said set mu to equal m
b, this is what it looks like.
So epsilon-- I'm
just introducing
something which is a counting
parameter, and it's 1.
I could also make alpha
s the counting parameter,
but I actually want to stick
a number in for alpha s,
so alpha s is going to
disappear in the next line,
and I'll just keep the epsilon,
which is just telling me
the contribution is
coming from this order.
So you have some choice here
for how you define the b quark
mass, OK?
You could use the pole mass,
pole in the b quark propagator.
Or you could use
the m s bar mass.
Or you could use some
other definition.
And it's raised
to the 5th power.
So whatever definition
you pick, it
can be pretty sensitive to that.
So let me tell you
what the results look
like in three different
schemes for that mass.
So let's first do
the pole scheme.
This is the same.
We have m b pole
to the 5th power,
and then we'd write out
what the series looks
like in that scheme.
You look like you're
doing pretty good
when you're at one loop.
You went down by a factor of 5.
But then you go into
two loops, and you
find that your
correction at two loops
is pretty much the same size
as your correction at one loop.
So you say, well,
let's use m s bar.
That changes the
perturbative series.
And maybe you think you're
doing a little bit better
because at least, well--
(CHUCKLING) but
this guy got bigger,
and this guy is
bigger than that guy,
so it's also not really working.
Well, if the phenomenology
is as accurate as I told you,
you must imagine that
there is something that
does work better than that.
Indeed there is.
So there's other mass games,
and I'll talk about one of them,
continuing this table,
where we switch to something
called the 1S mass.
Now [INAUDIBLE] looks like that.
We're very happy.
Or at least we're much happier
than we were over here.
So what is the 1S mass?
The 1S mass is
basically that you
take half the perturbative
mass for the epsilon system.
So the 1S mass is m b
b bar system calculated
perturbatively, divided by 2.
OK, we'll talk more about why
this is working in a minute.
Let me also write down--
these are conversion formulas
because you calculate the decay
rate once and for all, so
you calculate the first line.
Then you know how to
convert between schemes,
and that's what's causing the
perturbative serious to differ.
So m b pole is equal
to m b m s bar,
and there's a
series that relates
them that looks like that.
And I could put in numbers here.
And so that's what's
changing the numbers when I
go from this line to this line.
Basically, kind of the 5
hours of 0.09 that you get
takes you from here to here.
We could also think about
switching from the pole scheme
to this m b 1S scheme.
We have a different series.
It still doesn't
look very convergent.
The numbers look small, but--
this is supposed to be a 6--
but this number here is
bigger than that number.
So that when I stick this
series and combine it together
with this series
for the pole mass,
then I get that series
at the top of the board.
And the problem is
not in the m b 1S.
The problem is in the m b pole.
And the problem
in the m b pole is
being reflected in this
series that relates
them and its poor convergence.
AUDIENCE: Can you explain
[? what ?] [? m ?] [? b ?]
[? bar ?] [? being ?]
[? perturbative ?] [? means? ?]
IAIN STEWART: Yeah,
so you calculate--
so you can think of calculating
the Coulomb potential between b
and b bar, and that will
give you alpha s corrections
to just the mass.
So you have 2 m b plus Coulomb
potential plus, you know,
radiative corrections to that.
And you keep dressing it
up and just perturbatively
calculate as if it was a
Coulomb problem, a QED problem,
the mass of the b b bar state,
and then you divide by 2.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
IAIN STEWART: Yeah
AUDIENCE: But you just pretend?
IAIN STEWART: There's
nonperturbative corrections
to it, but what we're extracting
from it is the series.
OK?
I'll explain more why
it's going to work,
why this is, like, a reasonable
choice, and we'll come to that.
OK, so the lesson here is simply
that the choice of mass scheme
has a big impact on the
perturbative series.
And we haven't yet figured
out why some things work
and why some things
don't, but we will.
It's absolutely crucial
to use the right one.
Otherwise, the predictions
will not be good.
Well, physically,
we can actually
argue right away why m
b pole is not so good.
And that's because,
physically, there is no pole.
There's no pole in
the quark propagator.
And that is because
of confinement.
So we use this notion of
pole and a quark propagator
when we're doing
perturbation theory.
But nonperturbatively, it's
not a well-defined notion,
or at least there doesn't
really exist poles
in quark propagators.
So it's only perturbatively
a good notion.
So I'll say it's only
perturbatively meaningful.
And in reality, it's ambiguous,
it's an ambiguous notion.
And you can think that the
amount by which it's ambiguous
is related to
hadronization, which
is set by the scale lambda QCD.
So there's an
ambiguity in what you
mean by a pole mass physically
due to nonperturbative effects.
Now, when we set up HQET,
we actually used m pole.
So we're using a questionable
physical parameter.
So when we did these
phase redefinitions,
we were actually using
the pole mass scheme
because we were expanding
about mass shell.
So if you were to
do other things,
you can think about
getting to other choices
and implementing
them in the HQET.
No problem with doing that.
But there does exist
another operator
that we sort of dropped without
thinking too hard about it.
So if we switch to using
a different mass scheme,
there's some delta
m, which you can
think of as a series in
alpha s, which we wrote
on the board a moment ago.
And where that delta
m would show up
is that you would have kind of
an L delta m operator, which
would just be exactly delta
m, and then Q v bar Q v.
That would be left over
when we cancel the masses
in the Lagrangian, if you like.
That's one way of
thinking about it.
So we have an extra term
in the Lagrangian in HQET.
And now you can ask, well,
if we have an extra term,
we'd better worry
about power counting.
And it turns out
that the way we can
understand why m s
bar wasn't working
is related to power counting.
So in m s bar, if you
look at what delta m is,
delta m is m bar
itself times alpha.
But by power counting,
you don't want
something that's growing
with m b in the Lagrangian.
m b is suppressed by alpha,
but it's alpha at m b that is
providing [? some ?]
[? suppression, ?]
but that's only 0.2, and
that's actually just not enough
suppression to get rid
of the big m b here.
You don't get--
you go from 5 GV--
you know, there's
some number in front.
Maybe you get down
to 1 and 1/2, 2 GV,
but you're not getting down
to a small enough value.
So parametrically, this is just
not good, both parametrically,
because it grows with m b,
and numerically it's too big.
It's not order lambda
QCD, which would be OK.
So parametrically
and numerically,
delta m is just too big for
HQET power counting in this m
s bar scheme.
You'd include an operator
that effectively is on average
larger and more important than
your kinetic term because the v
dot D operator-- v dot D is
counting like lambda QCD,
and it had v dot D with two Q's.
Now you have something delta
m with two Q's, and if it's
on average larger,
then you're messed up.
So that's why actually
physically the m b bar
is not a good choice.
You can think about it from the
effective theory from that way.
m b bar is actually
a mass that's--
you're supposed to
think of it as a mass
that you use for
high-energy physics,
for physics really high energy,
above the b quark mass scale.
Then it's a good parameter.
We're now doing physics
below the b quark mass scale,
and this is just
one way of seeing
why it's not such a
good parameter there,
because the perturbative
corrections are just too big.
So what about this 1S mass?
So here, it turns out that
if you calculate delta m,
you get--
in the same way that you think
about corrections to hydrogen
being order alpha squared,
you get m b 1s alpha squared.
And numerically,
that's small enough
when you put the coefficient in.
So it still doesn't make us
feel very good because it grows
with m b, but if I just
care about numerics
and I'm doing b
quark physics, it
works because the alpha
squared is enough suppression
that this is a good
mass scheme, and that's
why the perturbation theory
treating as order lambda
QCD numerically, if
not parametically.
Is OK.
Now, if that doesn't
sit pretty with you,
you can do something
even more fancy,
and we'll talk about one example
of more fancy a little later
on, where you basically, instead
of having m show up there,
you have some parameter
R, and you have something
that you can just pick.
And so you could
pick a scheme here
where R is of order
lambda QCD-- by however,
maybe you pick it be 1 GV or
500 MeV or whatever you like.
So you can make up a
scheme where this is true,
and then both parametrically
and numerically you're OK.
And these schemes also work
just as well as the 1S scheme.
So we can get more
fancy and also satisfy
our formal requirement.
All right, so that's kind
of phenomenological numbers
and a bit of physics.
Let's come back to some
mathematics and talk about what
renormalons are mathematically.
Is there a mathematical
way of characterizing
what's going wrong?
What if I didn't think
about this physics?
Could I do a calculation and see
that something's going wrong?
And the answer is yes.
So first I have to
teach you a few things,
if you don't know them
already, about the asymptotics
of perturbative series
in quantum field theory.
And these are actually
not convergent series.
So they are what are
called asymptotic series.
So what's the definition
of an asymptotic series?
So we say a function has
an asymmetric series, which
I'll write as follows.
Some coefficients.
And we'll just call the
expansion parameter alpha.
You can think of it as
alpha s, if you like,
but this is just
math, so you don't
have to think about it as
anything but the expansion
parameter.
And we say that a function
has an asymptotic series if
and only if the
following is true.
f of alpha minus the partial
sum up to some level n
is less than kind of
the scaling that you
would get from the next term in
the series, which is n plus 2,
for some numbers K N plus 2.
So that's actually a
quite different definition
than what you would have
for a convergent series.
For a convergence
areas, you would
say that you could pick
any epsilon you like here.
You could make the N
big enough that this
would get close to that.
Here, I'm just saying
that it's less than this
with some power of alpha.
So imagine that I
pick alpha to be 0.1.
The thing is that this K
here could still grow with N,
and that actually will happen.
So the truncation
area in some sense
is not being bounded in
these asymptotic series.
And perturbation theory
and quantum field theory
is generically of
this structure,
and I'll show you
some examples of that.
It's asymptotic rather
than convergent.
So when you do a
QFT calculation,
a kind of typical result if
you work out some asymptotics
is that you would have
these fn coefficients that
are some power of a, and
then times an n factorial.
And that's kind of how they're
scaling as n is getting large.
You can think about the number
of diagrams as just growing,
but even when diagrams
are not growing
you can get these n factorials.
So that means if you're
fixing alpha as some value
of the parameter, and no
matter how small you take it,
at some order in
perturbation theory,
you're basically running out
of gas, and your truncation--
you start to--
your predictions start
to grow and diverge.
So the corresponding
values of these K's,
if you had these f's
that were of that form,
would be that the K's
are basically growing
in the same way.
So you'd need larger and
larger numbers in order
to satisfy the definition
of asymptotic over there,
and having these large
numbers you're never
able to satisfy convergent.
So the series has zero
radius of convergence.
And then you wonder, why
have we been teaching
you quantum field theory?
[CHUCKLES] That's true.
So what do we know?
Even though these
series are asymptotic,
we can still make use of them.
So typically what happens is
that the series will decrease.
For a while, it'll look
like it's convergent,
and then it'll start diverging.
And you can characterize
where it starts to diverge.
And I'm not going to go
through all the algebra,
but I'll just tell
you some facts.
And so you could
imagine that you're
doing some perturbation
series, and it
looks like it's going well.
Things are converging.
But then, [? some ?]
[? things ?] don't start to go
so well.
So think of what
I'm plotting here
as the partial sum
of your perturbation
theory at N-th order.
I sum up all the connections up
to N, so it's like the series
that I was writing over here.
It's this thing.
Now, in perturbative
QED, perturbative QCD,
we're never getting
more than a few terms.
So you could say,
well, OK, maybe I
don't care so much about this.
And in QED, that's
actually the case.
You don't really care
so much about that.
But in QCD, actually,
the turnover
happens already around
three loops, and so as soon
as you start including two loop
corrections this is something
you have to care about.
Now, you can say, well,
the best thing I can do
is stop doing perturbation
theory at some N star
because that's kind of
where it looks the best.
Like, I've gone toward
something in it.
And that actually is
not such a bad thing.
And it turns out you can
characterize actually
the mistake you're
making by stopping there,
and the mistake you're
making by stopping
there is of the following form.
So it's an exponential
in 1 over alpha.
So you would never be able
to see kind of the correction
that you'd need to get to
the correct value, which I'm
imagining is on the axis
here, in perturbation theory
because this doesn't have
a perturbative expansion.
And I'll actually show you
that kind of the bad behavior
here and this gap are
related to power corrections.
And they're exactly
related to this connection
that I was telling you between
perturbative corrections
and large-order asymptotics
and power corrections.
This type of
exponential is something
that we can relate
to power corrections,
and we'll see how that pans
out, although we might--
probably won't get
there until next class.
OK, so this is
kind of a prelude,
and now we're going to
go into more detail.
And it turns out, in order
to go into more detail here,
that, much as you make
Fourier transforms
to explore another
space, we're going
to do a transform to
something called Borel space.
So it turns out
that, when you have
a divergent series or
an asymptotic series,
there's still degrees
of divergence.
And we can classify
how divergent
it is by using something
called the Borel transform.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] will the
series still be asymptotic?
IAIN STEWART: So no, it's not.
Yeah, so 1S mass--
let's see.
Yeah, it is still
asymptotic, but it's--
in a way that I'll
describe once we understand
what this Borel is,
it's much less divergent
than the other series,
than the pole series.
If you think about
the pole series
as being degree-0 divergent,
then this is like a few orders
down less divergent.
So once we define less
divergent of a divergent series,
then I'll be able to
make that more precise.
It's a question of when
power corrections come in.
And if you look at,
like-- so physically,
the 1S mass is a physical
thing for an epsilon state.
If you look at how power
corrections come in,
then they're suppressed
because there's
an ambiguity between power
corrections in perturbation
theory.
If the power corrections
are suppressed,
you have less ambiguity in
the perturbation theory.
That's another way
of thinking about it.
But the answer to your question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
IAIN STEWART: It
basically affects this a.
All right, lots
of good questions.
Let's see how we get there.
So when I transform, I'm going
to call the transform function
capital F, and I'm going to
call its argument B for Borel.
And so what's the definition
of the Borel transform?
We're going to
define it as follows.
There's a first-order
term, and I'm just going
to put a delta function there.
The real thing that
matters is the series
of terms that come next.
And instead of having F
to the n alpha to the n,
I'm going to divide by
an extra n factorial,
and that's the
definition of, given
a set of F's, how
I construct what's
called the Borel transform.
And because of the n factorial,
I get improved convergence,
so the n factorial is
making it converge better.
So if there's a transform, there
should be an inverse transform.
So here's the inverse transform.
It's an integral from 0 to
infinity, b over alpha F of b.
And that would get
me back to the F.
So if you have a
convergent series
and you think of
this transform, then
you just can go back and
forth, and you get back
to the original-- the function
that you started with.
So if you have some
series that's like that,
you get back--
you could calculate
that series, and you
get some F of alpha just
before Borel transforming.
If you do this Borel
transform, then
you calculate this
integral, you get back
the same F of alpha from
the inverse transform.
Let me give you an
example that shows you
that, if you have
a divergent series,
it's not too crazy to define
the sum of the divergent series
by using these transforms.
So I claim that, for
a divergent series,
where F of b and the
inverse transform exist--
so if we start with
a divergent series,
but these things exist,
then we could just
use this transform as a
way of defining F of alpha.
So let me give you
a simple example
of that to convince
you that it's not
such a bad thing to do.
So let's consider
the following series.
Just an alternating
series, but alpha
is a parameter greater than 1.
That series doesn't converge.
Of course, for alpha less
than 1, it would converge.
And if I asked you
what it should be,
you would say, well, I
calculate for alpha less than 1,
I analytically continue,
and it's 1 plus alpha.
Well, that's one way
of getting there.
Another way of getting there
is using this Borel transform.
So if you calculate
it here, F of b,
you sum up 0 to infinity
minus b to the n--
once you put the
minus 1 in there
and there's an
extra n factorial.
So that's e to the minus
b, perfectly well-behaved
function.
And then you have to do an
interval, 0 to infinity, db.
You could have e to the minus
b over alpha times the F of b,
which is e to the minus
b, and that just gives
you alpha over 1 plus alpha.
And this is a perfectly
well-defined interval
for large alpha.
Large alpha is even
making it better.
So the integral is
perfectly well-defined,
and we get an
answer that we like.
OK, so this Borel
transform is a useful way
of dealing with
divergent series.
The real question
is, what happens
if the inverse
transform doesn't exist?
And that's what's going
to be the thing that we're
most interested in.
So if the F of the integral,
integral over the F of b
doesn't exist,
then the integrand
can tell us about the severity
of the singularities, I.e.,
the severity of the divergence.
And that's the real power
of this Borel method.
So let's do another example,
where actually things
will diverge.
So let me take F n to be
a to the minus n, n plus k
factorial.
And if we do that Borel
transform of that--
if you have a series,
you can do it.
And there's only one piece
of it that we care about,
so I'm just going
to write that piece.
So there's this piece that has
a kind of pole-like structure,
and it has a pole at b equals a.
And what you say is you
call this pole a renormalon.
This is the renormalon.
You call it a b
equals a renromalon.
So you're characterizing
the renormalon
by where that pole is.
A renormalon is a
flavor of a particle.
This has nothing to
do with a particle.
Usually, you think
of poles as having
something to do with
particles, and that's
where the name comes from.
It's due to 't Hooft.
Blame him.
[CHUCKLES]
So if a is less than 0,
your integration contour
is positive, and the pole
is on the other side,
so you don't have a problem.
The inverse transform exists.
These are called UV renormalons.
They still can guide
the perturbation theory,
and they can be
important for thinking
about why the
perturbation theory is
behaving the way it is, but you
can do the inverse transform.
The real ones that are
kind of problematic
are a greater than 0
because then the pole
is on the integration contour,
and we can't do the transform.
So we're integrating d
b from 0 to infinity,
and we just have a pole sitting
on the axis, so what do we do?
So you could think
about characterizing
how poorly behaved a
perturbation theory is
by looking at these
poles, and that's
kind of what I meant by having
some kind of notion of how
divergent a series is.
So you look in this Borel space,
and you look at the real axis,
and those poles actually
can be on both sides.
The most severe pole is the one
that's closest to the origin,
and that has the
smallest value of b.
And you can see if you
have a small value of b,
then you're multiplying here
with some large numbers.
So if a was 0.1, you'd be
multiplying by 10 to the n.
So these guys are more severe.
As you go to larger values,
you get additional suppression
from this a to the
n, so if a was--
if you went all the way out to
100, then you'd have 1 over 100
to the n.
That's good, but
factorial eventually wins.
So it's still divergent, but we
look like it was a lot better.
OK?
So you can characterize how
severe the series is diverging
by the location of these poles.
And you can characterize
the ambiguity
in doing an integration by--
if you just think
about one pole,
you can characterize
the ambiguity,
so let's just imagine
there's one pole.
You can characterize
the ambiguity
by going above or below.
So you have two possible ways
of defining the interval.
You don't know which to pick.
One is to go above.
The other is to go below.
And then you can think
about what the ambiguity is.
And the ambiguity
is the contour 1.
Call this c1.
This is c2.
The ambiguity is c1 minus c2,
and that is circling the pole.
So you can look at the
residue of the pole,
and that gives
you the ambiguity.
So what we'll do
next time is we'll
look at an example
in perturbative QCD.
We'll see that there's a
series that has a renormalon,
and we'll find it.
And then we'll look
at the residue,
and we'll find actually that
out will pop lambda QCD.
So we'll see, we'll calculate,
for some perturbative series,
that the pole mass really has
an ambiguity of order lambda
QCD by using this
technique of going around
a residue of a pole.
OK?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] when we
say that the b quark has a 4 GV
mass, what's the mass?
[INAUDIBLE]
IAIN STEWART: Yeah, so if
you say the b quark has,
like, 4.2 GV mass,
that's the m s bar mass.
If you say it has
a 4.73 GV mass,
that's like the m b 1S mass.
And if you look at how the
PDG measures the b quark mass,
they measure it in
one of these schemes
that I'm telling you
about, like the 1S scheme.
They [INAUDIBLE]
result for that.
You can convert between the
1S and the m s bar mass.
The m s bar mass is a
perfectly well-defined quantity
it doesn't actually
have a renormalon, OK?
That's not its problem.
The pole mass has a renormalon.
The m s bar mass, its problem
is related to power counting
in the low-energy theory.
It's a good mass for
high-energy physics.
It's a bad mass for
low-energy physics.
That's the problem with m s bar.
It's not it's not a technical
problem, that it has a--
[INAUDIBLE] severity
of renormalon.
It can have a
higher-order renormalon,
but it doesn't have the
same severity of renormalon
as the pole mass.
The pole mass basically
has the most severe
possible renormalon, which
is, in some units, 1/2,
so there's an extra 2 to the n.
We'll talk about that next time.
So basically, it's the u equals
1/2 renormalons that really
are causing a problem in
perturbative [? QCD ?]
because they're the
most important-- there's
higher-order ones.
Even alpha s actually
has a normalon,
alpha s in the m s
bar scheme, I suspect.
[CHUCKLES] But even up to
five loops you won't see it,
or it's very hard to see.
Let's stop there.